yeah this feels all right yeah yeah yeah
okay this this feels better
dude are my
i'm
cool
toes are out of frame i was about to say
this literally first
[Music]
i think that's what we learned during
quarantine is
oh we need more than one stream of
income yeah because i was on the road i
was about to be on the road more than
i've ever been on the road like i was
i was did my 10 year comedy anniversary
and i was like about to be a touring
headliner i dropped my own comedy
special
i was doing a tour named after the
comedy special and then
you know
come back from a gig and then the next
day it's like
well you you got rid of your you moved
into a van yeah so we're like i'm going
on this tour and then
actually the cove it happened before the
van the van happened because of covet so
i was doing the same thing i had just
gotten booked with this entertainment
company for like a tour across the
southeast and that was like gonna be my
first time like leaving florida to go do
comedy and so i was like yeah we made it
big time you know yeah yeah um went like
gave up my place like moved to
tallahassee into this house we could
start rehearsing for the tour and then
the world shut down
so yeah so
they had luckily like the lease was paid
like for the house for like six months
so it's like all right you got six
months to figure your [__] out
[Music]
and that's when the van that's when i
came i i decided i was like okay like if
i'm if i'm gonna be homeless in six
months like i'm
like there's a way i could be homeless
and do this like
you know what i mean so
i just decided to go for it the next
logical step is you live in a van with a
leaky roof i mean it's that easy if
there's one if there's one tip one thing
that's worked for me as far as like
making it in comedy it's
if you make it like necessary for your
survival you kind of do it yeah yeah
that's true
yeah and as as comedians we're we're
addicted to it so like it's like by any
means necessary like
and also like i'm autistic and i also
have adhd so those two things are
constantly at battle you know what i
mean so
like uh
like the like the autistic part of my
brain was like yeah we have to like plan
this out we have to figure out like the
right way to do this and the adhd part
of my brain was like if we stop to plan
i will die
so we just gotta move it's like uh like
it's like that dory like just keep
swimming just like it's that wow
yeah and and in researching you and
what's so cool
first off researching well research
i mean we're here with aj wilkerson this
is a comedian three years into the game
i think we first we first physically met
each other at the world series of comedy
at the punchline at the punch line and
you came up to me talking about
uh how much you like top breath
and right ten and the right ten and then
like we met other people in the hot
breath of verse there and i was like oh
my gosh it was like one of my first like
maybe experiences of like someone just
coming up to me and like naming things
in the hypertheverse like i like this
and this is so cool and so i was like oh
and then now like that was a little over
a year i went back and looked at the
photo we took a little over a year later
a year earlier and then now
you're like
what we call like a social media star a
social media comedian yeah like it
happened like just
it's like i meet you and then you know i
guess you got the hot breath bump and
then he's like yeah i did i got that i
got that hot breath bomb but what
but what what happened dude um
i think just that same thing like i was
talking about like just that like that
need in my brain to like keep swimming
you know
um
and
i uh i had at that point i think i was
already uh starting to feature for jason
muse so i was already working with like
jay from jay and silent bob right yeah
um and because this was in may 2021 yes
so that's when about about a year ago
from now yeah so okay um and i was doing
the world series the punch line was
actually my first satellite for the
world series and that was like my first
like
big like real festival because the only
festival i had done before that was
during covid so it was like uh streamed
you know so doing comedy in an empty
room exactly yeah
at my own reflection which is so
weird
uh but uh
but yeah i started like worked my way
through a bunch of different satellites
because it was i had the van so i was
able to just be in those different
cities yeah um
and uh
like i feel like i've been lucky because
like every step of the way i've had like
like either a mentor or somebody like in
this business
like
give me that like an extra little push
like when i needed it you know yeah so
like with the world series that was my
first satellite and i was uh i was in
like the y one of the wild card rounds
and i didn't advance but i got really
good feedback about my set but then like
he was like okay if you can change like
this this and this and i was like okay
so i went back and i started like
changing and working on it and i was
like okay i got rid of this this this
and this and moved these things around
and then i did my next satellite and
he's like dude that was amazing you did
everything i asked but i still didn't
advance so i was like you know and then
like there were new notes you know so
then i started working on the new notes
and i kept not advancing but then i i
got invited to vegas for the you know
like the whole main event yeah yeah yeah
um
and it was because i had kept showing
that improvement and kept like taking
those notes as like okay this is like
the challenge this is what i'm gonna do
to get better
and
you know even though i hadn't advanced
for many of the satellites i still made
it into like the top 100 and went to
vegas and then same thing i just kept
working at it you know what what were
some of those what were some of those
notes like that you were getting to like
improve on because what i've learned is
a lot of people that listen to this
they may not even do comedy yet they
literally may just like aspire to do it
and they don't even know where to begin
and i think you may have been making a
lot of young comic mistakes that you're
getting feedback on that you're able to
like refine and iron out kind of yeah so
it was that's kind of what it was like
one of the one of the main ones i
remember was um at that point like uh
when we talk about like comedy structure
and stuff like that like i i was at that
point i was going by like that old uh
the old adage like you know you put your
closer you put your best joke last your
second best joke first right so i had
this joke that i loved and it like
killed everywhere and it it did great at
the world series but it was a it was
like just an absurdist joke about like
masturbating you know and so the note
was he was like you like that's a
yeah like like in drive-through lines
you know like
yeah something very intellectual like
that yeah oh yeah uh great joke great
like icebreaker crowd you know yeah um
and he was like that's a great joke but
like you're not doing like feature sets
like this is like uh you're doing like
these are like competitive shows so you
have like seven minutes to let people
know everything they can about you
right and so it's like okay so like i
moved that chunk completely out i was
like if i need it i'll save it like for
one of the later rounds kinds of things
and so it was things like that like um
getting advice because like at that
point i had been kind of just working on
building up like sets and building like
an act you know yeah and so i was like
oh yeah i'll just take like the first
seven minutes of my act and that'll be
like what i'm using and there's
no like it doesn't work that way you
know what i mean
um
like you have to
do something that's gonna differentiate
you from the other all of the other
comics like everybody when you're at
that level like everybody's been vetted
as funny already you know so like what
do we need to know about you you know so
it was putting yourself into your
materials
and it was it would it it was not just
putting myself into my material more but
lead with that especially because like
um
being
autistic like i stim when i get up in
front of a lot of people i i stim like
my hands shake real bad like right now
like my legs bounce in and that's a
little bit of it yeah it's stimming it's
self stimulation gotcha so it's
basically like for me it works as almost
like a uh like a distraction
gotcha right like uh cause whenever i'm
anxious my i'm
fully in like fight-or-flight mode kind
of thing right yeah i'm not a fighter
uh
but so like the part of my brain's like
run away the other part of my brain's
like hit somebody you know
uh
but just from like the anxiety of
especially when i'm like around like in
big crowds of people yeah right and
that's why it's like uh when we were
talking earlier about like uh you know
before when i was just thinking about
comedy i was something i've loved my
whole life and wanted to do my whole
life
i just thought like i i thought it was
just like regular like uh like stage
fright or like
performance anxiety or whatever so i was
like well this is just not something
i'll ever be able to do because you
tried it once and like puked and didn't
even go up right i uh i wrote a full
five minutes and then puked like before
i even left my head like i couldn't make
it out of my house to go yeah wow um
but then after i got diagnosed and i was
working with a therapist and an autism
specialist and i got my medical
marijuana card and then one night i was
just very i was like you know what i
think i can
like
[Music]
i don't know how many comedy careers
have started with someone getting high
and been like we could do this yeah yeah
um but
it was it was like just that extra
little thing i needed to like make the
attempt you know what i mean and then
once like once you break the ice like
it's
it's pringles man like once once you pop
you just can't stop for sure you know
um so then this became like an addiction
and then i started like i realized like
how much it was helping like because
before that i kind of like withdrawn and
become like very hermity you know what i
mean
and now all of a sudden i was like
background people and i was like
rebuilding all of those social skills
that i had like thought were gone you
know wow so before you got diagnosed you
were like super like hermity you're
saying because you were married at one
time right i was married got divorced
and then once i got divorced and like
there wasn't someone who was like
contractually obligated to spend time
with me you know i just
stopped spending time with everybody wow
you know yeah so i just kind of
retreated and it was kind of like maybe
this just isn't the world for me you
know uh and then
comedy kind of like reintroduced me back
to society so yeah and something you've
i heard you i was referencing earlier
with researching you is you said you
want to like help educate people about
autism as well yeah so like what what do
you wish people understood because
honestly i don't know
i literally don't like know anything
beyond the word and maybe there's some
like shows i've seen yeah um i mean a
lot of it is like just
like
showing that it's like it's a mixed bag
like there can be a lot of negatives but
it's viewed much more negatively than
the reality of it you know what i mean
and so people tend to like write off
autistic people and
like as oh well they can't do anything
but like here like i figured out a way
to like
beat my brain
and like do this thing that i
love doing and now i figured out a way
to do what i love for a living so like
yeah my brain's not built for like
like a traditional society style job but
i figured out a way around it
so
i feel like it's that it's like giving
peop like giving us our due in in a
sense you know what i mean like you
can't just write us all off as like oh
well you're you have to be this you know
what i mean
um so it's a lot of that uh and also a
lot of that um like i said like mixed
bag like it's it's a spectrum right like
um like especially like in like the
media you only really get to see like
one brand you know what i mean
like uh like i have a a bit i've been
working on about like how i'm not a fan
of love on the spectrum
because uh again like uh it's it's like
cops right like they pick like the one
the cases that are going to look the
best on tv
like not the reality you know so they're
not getting like a full
they're not getting like showcasing the
full spectrum they're showing like one
color of it
yeah so that's kind of my thing and it's
the same thing like
people hear autism and they're like oh
like rain man autistic or like forrest
gump autistic and it's like well
you know both of those were like
characters played by not autistic people
yeah yeah right
so yeah it's that it's like oh no it's a
it's a real thing not just something tom
hanks played in a movie once so almost
like just like not stigmatized but like
almost like humanized like normalized
like yeah we're like people with autism
are still people who like you're a like
a working touring comedian like they're
it's not all like one specific
stereotype i guess yeah okay also like
that not like
you're
the outlook like people like autistic
people's outlook is only as negative as
the people around them make it
you know what i mean like if you look at
autism it's like oh this is such a
disability and such a shame
then that autistic person is going to
grow up feeling ashamed of how their
brain works
instead of trying to find the strengths
and how their brain works you know so
you treat people with kid gloves and
they grow up and they still have to have
kid gloves you know yeah so it's some of
that it's like like let us experience
our own challenges let us try and figure
it out for ourselves you know it's
interesting you weren't diagnosed until
you were 30 i think anthony hopkins just
recently as well and yeah in his like
70s yeah so i guess it's almost i guess
as more awareness and information gets
out there beyond like this stereotype of
people with autism then that seems to be
maybe opening up a little bit more as
well
right and i feel like that's kind of
where i'm at
as like
um i like it's weird like i get like
really cool messages from other autistic
people and family members and stuff so
it's cool like i feel like i i get to be
a part of that like bringing to the
light you know what i mean
um
but yeah like with anthony hopkins like
a big like uh like trait or like uh
uh
thing related to autism is masking
right and like we're talking about
anthony hopkins not getting diagnosed
until in his 80s right anthony hopkins
this incred literally like academy
award-winning oscar award-winning actor
right
acting as masking
like
before i knew it was autism like i just
thought like it was like such bad like
this really bad anxiety right so i would
basically like
hide my anxiety like and just just
pretend like oh this is what like a
normal person like oh this is what my
friends are doing so i'm going to act
like my friends are acting huh i'm going
to try and blend in so nobody realizes
like i'm the broken one right
so it's like it's like it becomes like
for some of us it's like a life skill it
becomes like active camouflage and same
thing like i'm talking about like he
found a way to use that to his advantage
and make it a career so he was able to
go 80 years
without needing to like pursue a
diagnosis he found like the workaround
for him you know
and
some of us some of us can do that and
find that workaround on their own i
needed like i
not having a diagnosis like it was
another not anything i'd ever considered
until somebody else pointed it out you
know what i mean and then when i started
going through the process and every
every doctor i'd get to was like yeah we
got to move you up the chain because
like there's something going on here you
know and so that like kind of coming to
terms with it as you're getting
diagnosed with it is like a weird thing
you know but it's also
it also helped so much because it helped
me like put pieces together and figure
out like okay instead of just trying to
like keep putting my head down and
trying to do things the way everybody
else does them
maybe if i can figure out some different
ways to do it so like i went back to i
was i had already gone back to school
and like got my bachelor's degree in
graphic design so instead of like trying
to be in an office full of people and
burning myself out i found remote work
so i could work from home you know
like i found little workarounds like
that but still not enough to keep like
it was enough to keep me
surviving but not living if that makes
yeah that's sense right
i know because it's all the knowledge
now
but that's really cool that it clearly
has a big impact on people because i
mean you have hundreds of thousands of
followers on social media now and i feel
like maybe it's it's kind of like your
feedback in the world series of them
pushing you
to put yourself out there more to even
though you were neuter comedy it's like
what is unique about you what is unique
about your own life that you can bring
to the stage that isn't a generic
masturbating and a drive-through joke
right you know what i mean and and so
there that was that big note was like
don't like you can't start with
something generic you have seven minutes
like start with you yeah and then the
other part was like because of like the
way like my shake and i'm you know i'm
shaking like a leaf kind of on stage
sometimes and they're like even though
like you're speaking confidently and
things like that like if you're not a dr
and if you have a short set and you
don't address that immediately
like you know what i mean so i moved
started moving my set around and
starting playing with like different
structures and then realized like
through playing with those different
structures like oh i can move some other
things around and started like
kind of figuring out how to like more
like properly structure and act versus
like i got five minutes let me add it to
the other stuff i've got i've got five
minutes let me add it to the other stuff
i've got yeah
um
and then
but that like trying to study and work
on the structure of my act
like kind of forces you to develop new
material because you're like well i have
like i don't have anything that goes
from here to here like how do i connect
these ideas well now i got to write
something that connects those ideas yeah
but getting personal can be easier said
than done especially right newer in
comedy i mean it probably took me eight
years to really start like getting
really introspective and start talking
about things i'm embarrassed about or
things about my personal life that i
wouldn't normally you know just reveal
to our strangers or friends you know so
like how how were you able to start
excavating these personal topics like
are you asking specific questions or
what's that turns out when you withdraw
from society and become an introvert you
already are doing those things like
you're already like
internalizing so many things and like
like trying to figure out like what's
wrong with you on the inside so you're
already going through all of those
things so it basically it's like okay
now that i'm comfortable like being on
stage i know how to write a joke and
like i'm i'm
i'm
confident in my ability to talk about
something that's personal to me and
confident to know it's funny like
because nobody wants to tell something
that's like deeply personal to
themselves and then watch it bomb in
front of 80 strangers right
so like it was one of those things was
like okay i just spent like you know
like
a year year and a half like developing
material and learning how to write jokes
and learning how to write you know
material and be funny and now that i've
got all this experience under my belt
now let me go back and try and like
start to like looking at some of the
things that i want to dig deeper into
and what do i want to say about this
thing that's really important to not
just me but a lot of people and it's one
of those things that if i [__] it up
pardon the language
but
if i mess it up like people are going to
be angry with me you know and it still
happens occasionally
you know but like i'd say like even with
like the following and stuff that i've
gotten now like
one out of every you know
seven 800 comments or whatever like i'll
get i get like two or three negative
messages or comments a day like it still
happens like not ever you can't please
everybody of course you know yeah but it
was one of those things like i had to i
didn't i didn't know that i was funny
enough to talk about those things
without
failing entirely
you know and i don't know if you're like
this but like once you start to get a
little more experience under your belt
you can like have an idea and that first
time you write it down you already know
with like 85 confidence this is going to
get a laugh yeah i hope but you're right
you really do that's why it's 85 it's a
lot like meteorology yeah yeah like
this has a 72 percent chance of laughs
we all hope but until you get on that
stage is when you really know right yeah
but
when you get to that point and then
you're like okay and then you can like
okay i'm gonna take this thing that i'm
like 72 percent confident in and i'm
gonna run it through like two or three
mics and then like see where what needs
adjusting run it through a couple more
mics see what it needs adjusting and
okay now this bit is
what i thought was 72 percent uh i might
have guessed high but now i've polished
it up enough that i know like in the
field it's getting laughs 90 of the time
yeah you know so it's it's that i guess
like
building the confidence in your joke
writing and your like ability to be
funny to start looking at those
introspective things like i think that's
the i think that's like
i haven't met a comedian yet that
doesn't have imposter syndrome you know
what i mean like none of us really like
a hundred percent believe in ourselves
you know oh yeah um
so it's a little bit of like
that it's like if you can figure out a
way to like beat that a little bit you
know what i mean and then and start
getting introspective
yeah um
you just have to have the confidence to
do it you know and i think that
confidence does grow from just figuring
out how to be funny first i think a lot
of younger comics especially like
they see like bill burr
say you know
women should not be paid as much as men
or something like that and they're like
oh i want to go have a hot take like
that it's like well he spent a couple
decades developing the craft of comedy
and make these points it's like learn
the rules and then you break them so
it's like how can you make your dog
funny how can you make your job funny
and kind of slowly learn how to write
funny material and then you can start to
get more introspective as you get more
confident in your writing
ability no it's the exact same thing
with exactly like with heavy topics yes
and like and that's the other thing it's
like a lot of like young comics today
it's like no we're going to talk about
politics and we're going to talk about
like all of these like really heavy
subjects and it's like
dude you can't make people laugh with
dick jokes it's got to be funny come on
man you got to be funny you got to start
with the basics got to be funny first
yeah the fun the funny the mentals
yes all right we'll cut that out all
right that was so whack
i just do i just like cancelled out all
of our good insight we were sharing it
was good until he said fundamentals and
then fix it felix really ruined the
podcast there
so let's um let's get into the whole
social media situation here yeah because
i just had katherine blandford on here
who
just went viral she went viral like a
few weeks ago
and she was like still trying to even
like
she was still trying to even we talked
about imposter syndrome she's like it's
still think at any moment it's all gonna
disappear you know and they're gonna
like be like oh we're just kidding like
it wasn't we're gonna take all those
followers back or she was starting to
work with david spade and she the whole
time she thought
oh when i get to the hotel they're gonna
say ashton kutcher is gonna come out and
say punk'd
but
the whole social media situation is so
interesting for us comedians because it
is like we're seeing
everyone is now just posting all of
their stand-up clips and they're hoping
something goes viral and
for you it like it worked and like you
know you have
at the timing of this interview over 400
000 followers on tick tock and over 100
000 on instagram so like what
what were you what did you what do you
think you did
to get these followers or like
like for me i'm like just blindly
posting whatever like there's no real
thought behind it or whatever like what
what is kind of your approach to social
media um
so that's it's definitely a lot of that
in the beginning it was like just kind
of throwing things at the wall and
seeing what worked
and then like um
like i had a couple
uh like crowd work kind of clips and
like just things like that
start to get like a little bit more
views and then like
my tick tock went like uh
like it it started slow and then it just
like it went faster and faster
and so eventually it stopped at like
78 000. and then i was like okay now
like what do i do now you know
like because that's kind of like what it
is it's
okay going viral on social media is a
lot like calling an emergency town
meeting without having a speech prepared
like everybody shows up and they're like
all right we're here what now and you're
like
give me a minute i'll get right back to
you you know
so it is it's a lot like that but then
um
like i just think like those
interactions
um it was something
like something about the crowdwork
interactions and something about like um
we talk about like like comedians that
have like attitude and things like that
like with the specific material like
what's the attitude going to take
towards this what's the attitude towards
you gonna take towards that but there's
also like
there's like a feeling that
that like comics convey to the audience
right like you the audience can tell
when a comedian is having fun they can
tell when a comedian is nervous they can
tell
when they're drunk you know what i mean
yeah for sure and
but a lot of that is
it's that it's like i feel like people
can tell that i'm having a good time
and so like there's something in them
that's like look at him go you know i
feel like it's that
um
and it's kind of like uh
i'm terrible with names as a thing i
have but the old like the original like
that roast comic uh don rickles yes don
rickles yeah okay don rickles could call
anyone any name he wanted because you
could tell it was tongue-in-cheek like
you could tell there was no malice
behind it no like ulterior anything like
he said it because it was funny and
clever and he's like smirking like hope
like waiting for you to be in on the
joke with him right yeah yeah and
because he was able to convey that and
the audience could feel that
that's what like made him special right
yes and i feel like comics are so
like focused on like i want to be cool
or i want to convey this
instead of just like
what are you like what how are you
normally like what's what are your
characteristics that are the best you
know what i mean like show people that
i'm i love having a good time and i'm
one of those people that like when other
people are laughing i'm a contagious
laugher and then when i'm on stage like
especially especially once it's going
well and i feel like i'm on a roll
i'm already laughing imagining them
laughing at the next thing
right so like i feel like that kind of
is conveyed through like even on video i
feel like there's a part of it that you
can just tell yeah yeah so i really
think that's like the like the different
thing that people like noticed with my
videos uh but that was like again just
on tick tock right and like my tick tock
kept growing eventually uh a hundred
thousand um and then it like i kind of
creeped and crawled a little bit
more um until i i just decided i was
like i'm gonna get like take all of the
things that i'm doing and i'm gonna
start like mixing it up i'm gonna start
trying to add in more types of content
see what people like see what people
don't like
because it is kind of a numbers game
yeah how often are you posting
right now not a lot because that's the
other thing i realized was like that
that first like like like if you when
you go viral there's like this panic as
a creator because like i said like what
do i say like what do i do now right but
that's kind of because that's what the
platforms make you think you have to do
right like they tell you like the only
way to really
go viral is you have to post like five
times a day and you have to do this and
you have to were you doing that earlier
i tried yeah i went through different
periods of it and what i realized is if
like
i can go through cycles right if i i can
pull i can like bank a couple of videos
and i'm like hey this is gonna do really
well this is gonna do really well and
then i can be like okay i'm gonna put
these
10 videos out in a seven day period
and one of those videos will go viral or
like you know get like
uh half a million views and then those
people will a lot of those people will
go watch some of the other videos and
then those videos will get picked up by
the algorithm and start getting their
own following like kind of thing like
that yeah um but also typically by the
time you get to like that third video
and you're starting to get traction
the next video will kind of just keep
piggy backing off of that so i kind of
started doing that and
like just kind of like instead of just
putting out like something i was like
let me let me put out these things right
like let me kind of start curating what
i'm putting out
and that's what
started kind of working interesting what
were you putting out
different crowd work clips different
like old bits or something like that i
um i'd have like i i i
uh like was switching cameras and was
always having a hard time like getting
good tapes of stuff yeah but i'd get a
good tape and be like okay this bit like
i'm kind of like i don't use it anymore
so like i'm gonna wait until i get like
two more good clips and then i'll put
all of them out in the same week
gotcha you know
or oh i have this joke and i'm gonna put
this bit out but i can technically break
this bit into three videos
you know and do like a part one two and
three yeah well not necessarily that but
like these jokes are like this part of
the joke is funny by itself you don't
need the rest of the joke to laugh at
this part oh no right so this can stand
on its own so i can post like the full
joke or and i can post like this joke
the day before as like a teaser to the
full joke
okay kind of thing okay you know um and
then so that started working but then
the other thing that really helped was
and this is uh are you familiar with ben
brainard yes okay so ben brainard um
we linked up uh and i featured for him
for two shows in like chicago and we
were talking and he was like hey these
are some of like the things that i've
like found have helped like my videos in
the algorithm right like things like
making sure that you have like a full
vertical video without the black bars
like in like the different platforms can
recognize that and it like basically
it's like negative points you know what
i mean
um like towards like your algorithm
score yeah yeah
um
and then he was saying like uh facebook
and instagram right now
reels uh like have a higher
like or like weighted like a gpa like
reels are weighted heavier because
they're trying to compete with tick tock
so they're trying to bring get people to
like bring their videos to facebook and
instagram so i took cons like some of
the content that i had already banked
from
tick tock and having been on tick tock
for so long i hadn't i'd posted like two
reels on instagram in like three years
so it's like okay let me start putting
stuff on
instagram and then i figured out like a
cool like like a workflow thing right
like i realized like if i edited the
video like in facebook reels and posted
it on facebook first i could download it
with no watermark
because if you post something on tick
tock and then post it on instagram
instagram can recognize the watermark
negative points yeah but facebook with
no watermark i can download it from
facebook and then post it to instagram
and tick tock so i'm doing getting three
times the output with the same amount of
labor wow
right so i started figuring out things
like that and in 60 days of try like i
basically was like i i was like okay for
these like two months until something
works
i'm going to post a video at least every
other day
super attainable and like supportable a
lot of times i'm like three a day here
we go right and then day three i'm like
i hate now i was like i want to post
something every day but i don't have to
make a video every day or if i sit down
one day and make a bunch of videos i can
space those out right
and that also gives you the chance to
like mix up your content so you don't
have like three clips where you're
wearing the same shirt you know from the
same show
like how do i start mixing this up and
in 60 days on doing that on instagram i
went from like 7 000 followers to 130
000 followers and on facebook i went
from like
3 000 followers to 85 000 followers
posting
a stand-up clip every other day uh stan
sometimes it was a stand-up clip
sometimes it was uh like it would be
like a material clip sometimes it would
be like a crowd work clip or uh
sometimes it would be um
for like on my tick tock um i got like a
like a company reached out to me
um it was like a like a booking company
and they're like hey if you want to come
to like stay in our places for free when
you're in our cities all you have to do
is make us tick tocks like make us funny
videos so i made a couple like really
fun sketches and so since i had to do
them for my instagram anyway i was like
hey this is like free content for me so
i'll post them on my other platforms and
still shout you out on my other
platforms and so like i kind of mix in
stuff like that so
like sketches about like you know like
airbnb nightmares right you know so i'd
like post some stuff like that i'd post
um
just some like sometimes i'd figure out
like something random to post you know
but i just kept it going
and it just worked you know and like
some of the clips were like were better
clips than others
but uh
i think it was like trying to for me it
was figuring out like okay what's my
most effective way to do this because i
don't want to be one of those i don't
want to have to put out i don't want to
have to like drive myself to just put
out content every day because like
okay it's like our stand-up
if all you do every day is write 10 new
jokes and go tell those 10 new jokes
like
two years from now what happened to
those jokes you told
like eight years ago
you know what i mean
like
with stand-up like we're con we're
constantly trying to like
whittle down and refine and like uh like
cultivate and curate the best possible
version
of this like
like if you think about stand up as
content we're trying to curate like a
perfect hour of content right right so
why would we not try and do that with
our social media
like why would we not try and like
decide like hey this is what i want my
bar to be you know what i mean
um and so i started doing that and like
stuff that i was like okay well this
isn't like this isn't something that's
gonna work in my act and i don't i'm not
telling it on stage anymore so okay let
me try and figure out like a good like
put it like let make sure it puts its
best foot forward for social media and
it's something that if i were if i'm not
me and i scroll across this am i going
to find this funny am i going to find it
interesting am i going to engage with it
you know oh that's kind of that's
another good filter to put it through
though is if like
because a lot of times we feel obligated
or i feel obligated and i i feel like i
haven't
found a sustainable
system yet like a workflow yet because
like i have a ton of podcast content i
have a ton of stand-up content like i
have a ton of content but it's like
actually
posting it i i don't know i guess i
haven't found maybe the
i don't want to say motivation because i
know it's important but i haven't found
a consistency with it maybe a rhythm
with it yet
right but that's but that's why i feel
like that's why most people struggle
with it is because it's like you're
trying to fight like your natural rhythm
and your natural like just like with
comedic timing right like you develop
comedic timing over time like you figure
out your own comedic timing you can't
just go copy somebody else's
it doesn't work the same you know yeah
um like you can try and copy other
people's cadences and inflections but
then it just it's like is he trying to
do seinfeld right now you know yeah um
so i feel like it's like you you have
your own natural rhythm and then there's
like the rhythm that like
the out like the algorithm and the
platforms tell you you have like if you
you have to keep up with this fast-paced
thing or it's not going to work but
that's not true
if you are engaging and p like and i
think that's what it is like um
like are you also engaging with the
people commenting on your posts like are
you
do you pu are you putting out like a
like is there a vibe you like your
content is putting out like you know um
are you like does your community like
are you growing a community you know
what i mean and i have people like like
at this point like i posted something
the other day like you know that uh like
that really popular sound from all the
like the my money don't yeah yeah like
that right
well because i like shaken and stuff on
stage i happen to get like a really good
clip and angle and shot of me like i was
on stage and i was laughing and the way
i was laughing it literally looked like
i was doing this like shimmy
right so i put it to that music and then
like looped it you know what i mean like
a couple of times it was like
and like i literally just like somebody
commented he's like dude i love how you
just look like you're always having a
good time yeah that's great and so i
commented back i was like hey thanks a
lot like i am having a good time yeah
but i it's that it's like what are those
things that like the people like
it's social media you're trying to
convince strangers to like you right
yeah well you there you have like
friends and family members who were also
at one point strangers who you convinced
to like you so what are the things they
like about you show the people on social
media that
wow
because then they're they're going
that's going to make them like develop a
connection to you so even if you haven't
posted in three or four days they're on
your stuff so much that when you do post
you're popping up in their feeds
because they're liking every time you
post they're coming back and commenting
you know like if when you post on like
your instagram stories they're reacting
to your stories and like like commenting
back on like you know if there's
something in the story they're like oh
like this happens to me all the time you
know when i post like an adhd fact or
something yeah so it's it's kind of that
it's like
figuring i think it's it's not figuring
out how to get how to blow up on social
media it's how do you figure out how to
be yourself on social media
and i think if you can figure out a way
to do that then it'll work out bars
bars
yo
that's dope
that's a great tip and i think it may be
a good place to start is
like you said
would i watch this it's like that's a
big thing to put it through because i
think a lot of times like what will
people like what will what will get
catch the wave or whatever but you said
you you want to make sure you're posting
stuff that you enjoy and that you would
actually watch and consume and share so
that's actually that's a good place to
start with whatever you create so yeah i
do feel like it's like multifaceted but
like i said like if you ch like double
check like all of your technical stuff
like make sure your video is vertical if
you can like put the subtitles on the
video
that pumps it up in the algorithm
make sure you're using hashtags
um
i a little hashtag tip i guess hashtag
tip uh no
uh hashtag hashtag i what i do and
something i don't know if it works i
don't know if it's helped like
honestly i honest still don't fully
understand hashtags all right it's
basically bitcoin like uh they it's
helping i'm doing well with them don't
really understand how it works
but um i mix up my hashtags right so
like i go i like get a real ready i go
to post it on like tik tok or instagram
or anywhere
um
most people will just be like okay i'm
gonna pick like like four hashtags that
are all like
five billion or five million or whatever
but
uh
the more like the hashtags are kind of
weighted with like how many followers
you have right so when i had 10 000
followers i would find like a hashtag
with like 2 000 likes and then i'd find
a hashtag with like 10 000 likes and
then i'd find a hashtag with like 50 or
100 000 likes
and then like what would happen is like
let's say that 5 000 hashtag let's say
my video got some traction on that well
that traction would help me get traction
in the bigger hashtag
so if you're just posting big hashtags
you're never going to get traction in
there because you're you're not like
basically you need you need a fluffer
right so you i was you i was using the
small hashtags as fluffers to give me
traction with the bigger hashtags
[Laughter]
that that is a social media term yeah
yeah yeah yeah
that's gonna become a job title on
fiverr a social media fluffer that's
what it's called i would hire a social
media flapper
if somebody on linkedin like posted like
looking for work social media
hired you obviously know how to create
engaging headlines well i mean you're
really like the first
person that i've really heard talk about
social media and like that authentic way
of like
not how can you go viral but how can you
become yourself on social media and
everyone has a different answer for that
but that connection okay but see like
like uh you have a thing that i don't
have right like put it you put you have
thousands of hours of content right so
your issue is like trying to figure out
like okay what parts of this like
highlight my authenticity and what parts
of this like highlight the parts of my
personality that i think people like
right
um but when you figure out that thing
that that that like brings people to you
you have this giant content library
ready for them to make their way through
right right and like that's what happens
like when you start like going viral is
this video starts going like super viral
and then those people start trickling
down through oh let me look at all of
his other videos
so
you have to have something out there
um so i think that's what it is it's
trying to find out like figure out your
natural rhythm what's going to make you
comfortable with putting things out
there and trying to figure out how to
like be yourself and authentic and i
would say that's not just for social
media though i think that's also like
i feel like uh a lot of things like go
through like fads and phases and cycles
right and i feel like the current like
the
way comedy is heading currently is i
feel like we're heading towards a phase
where people want to hear about
you personally right like they want to
hear about like your life your insights
the things you've you know have learned
like
um you know the things that you trip up
on the thing you know the things that
you've [__] up you know whatever it is
they want to hear about you because they
want to connect with you you know
there's
millions and i would say billions
there's billions and billions of hours
of funny content on the internet
right so what's gonna make you so funny
and memorable that they're gonna be
happy that they left the house to come
see you
right like you have to give them
something that they can't find on the
internet and the only thing that any of
us have that isn't available on the
internet is us
you know yeah so i think that's what it
is
preach
preach oh man this is this is hot fire
yeah aj hot breath this is hot fire i
didn't rush specifically for this
well i knew when we met at the punch
line and you were like talking about hot
breath i was like yeah
i'll breath out you it's cool just to
meet people that like listen to it and
follow it in like real life and then
you're like oh well it's
it's like working
i love like the nuts and bolts of comedy
and like what we do so i do too yeah and
that's what's cool about this podcast is
it's like an under the hood kind of
thing yeah yeah yeah for sure um
and there's like dude like the
the mark norman thing with seinfeld
about just like locking yourself in a
room kind of until you can put something
on the paper yeah i have to do that
sometimes because of the adhd like
literally my mind is bouncing in so many
different directions all the time that's
like no we're gonna
in the closet all right yeah i mean i'll
go to the library sometimes like if i'm
sitting around i'm like i just can't
even sit here i just have to go so
there's a library uh
by
uh my girlfriend's house in kansas that
i will go to sometimes because i can
either get like one of the study rooms
you know or they have these little uh
like desk chair pod things that like
it's wrapped around like privacy-wise so
i can like literally face that towards
the wall and i'm in just like a little
pod yeah right yeah and so i'll do that
sometimes but literally like if i'm on
the road and like i had a an id and it's
like
okay like i'm in portland and i had this
funny thought about portland and i want
to make a portland joke so i can get a
clip for social media right of course
you know i will literally like in my
hotel room i will go and sit in the
closet with my notepad so like i can't
see the tv i can't you like i'll leave
my phone out there so i can't like get
distracted and start doom scrolling
through social media or play like a game
or any of that kind of stuff i'll sit in
the closet sometimes until i figure out
like okay this is oh i could say this
okay
like if i can get something down
you know um so sometimes i will do stuff
like that but there's i feel like that's
the stage i'm at in comedy like i still
feel like i'm like a comedy baby
right so i'm still trying to figure out
those things like i'm throwing a lot of
different like writing styles and ideas
and things at the wall and seeing like
what sticks and what's comfortable for
me
um and you're three years in right yeah
yeah i mean the rule of thumb is 10
years until you even start figuring out
what direction you want to go like until
you even start finding your voice let's
say 10 years and like
i mean and i
i mean i'm 12 years in but really like
with covid like i hit my 10-year
anniversary and then covet hit and like
you know then like
i feel like i'm just still getting back
into the rhythm of like live shows and
stuff so it's like i'm still trying to
figure it out i've interviewed people 20
years in the game who are like i'm still
trying to figure it out so it's like a
never-ending rubik's cube you know but
three years yeah you're
yeah you've got the whole world in front
of you
i hope so
but like i said i feel like that's the
thing that like everybody struggles with
because they're we're always chasing our
heroes right so it's like oh how does
seinfeld do it well i'm gonna do it
exactly how seinfeld does it well yeah
you do that for six years and you don't
get the seinfeld results and you're like
okay well what now like i wasted six
years because i wasn't willing to try
something else so i feel like that's the
key is like try all of the different
things just keep trying like you did
with social media yeah keep trying until
something sticks and that's true even
with like getting laughs on stage is
like you two out social media posting
and then the audience like you knows
what they like the audience in stand-up
will start to reveal what's funny about
you whether it's certain things you talk
about or how you say certain things or
facial expressions uh like that old
adage like uh
comic say funny things comedians say
things funny oh yeah like uh some of the
comics like i look up to the most and
like
i think like want like study the most
are those guys like i like two of my
favorite like right now they're theovon
and dusty slay because if you listen to
theo vaughn talk about anything
you're like he just says things funny
you know and dusty slay is the same way
and like so it's kind of that it's like
i want to like th there are different
skill sets i want to like develop and
like add in as i go you know and so
i feel like everybody has those certain
things they're like i want to do this
we'll learn how to do that like yeah
um being a swiss army knife is obviously
like the ultimate goal like everybody
wishes they could be a swiss army knife
but you can't you don't just get all of
the tools at once right so you like
start with the tools that you want the
most that you're going to be the most
engaged with and build from there
because you're going to put the most
work in getting those and if you like
you'll look back and be like oh i have
these five tools and these five tools
got me this far
and then you'll start working at
developing those other tools so that's i
guess what i've learned so far for sure
yeah it's all one one thing at a time
like i started out as one-liners
and then like started getting more
storytelling and then more animated and
act outs i'm still like working on all
of it but it is all like one
skill at a time and then over the course
of years you'll look back at me like oh
i have all these skills that i've just
developed over show after show after
show yeah i realized like
two years in
i had all of these like natural act out
points
and i wasn't doing i was like i'm not
like i'm doing
something but i'm not doing anywhere
near enough and then i started working
on like practicing weird facial
expressions in the mirror and like what
does my face do when i do this you know
yeah yeah and and also like vocal
inflections and stuff like i already my
voice already like shakes in a slightly
higher pitch some just from the anxiety
of being on the stage i was like okay
how can i right here i'm going to go low
you know what i mean like yeah so it's
just figuring it all out you're right
it's all of the little pieces and i will
literally talk about all of those little
[__] nuts and bolts all day long i'm
like count chocula
what is um
in your three years like what is like a
like a story you know i always ask
comics on here like a bad bombing story
or like getting booed or something like
what for you is there is there a show
that you'll just never forget that you
got it yeah okay right here in atlanta
no i don't think right
not technically atlanta but atlanta you
know what i mean uh the miami lounge
they used to do they used to do comedy
shows there a little while back
and uh
it was right after
uh it was maybe like a month month and a
half after i first like got the news
from like jay that i was gonna be like
going on the road and like featuring for
him yeah and that was basically you won
a contest to open for him
and then he loved you and then he was
like let's go on the road together just
for people that may not know but yeah
so i did my research i just wanted to
know i didn't want to skip over that big
moment in your career if you're going to
start opening your jb humble you know
but i just want people to know the
context
back to fluffing all right anyway
sorry okay but so i just started like
with that i think i had uh i hadn't even
done like my first gig with him yet i
just like had it on my calendar okay
you're feeling yourself right now oh
yeah you're you're the comedy's next big
thing oh yeah like well uh not so much
that but like yes like very proud of it
and stuff like that and like i'd already
posted and stuff about it and i can't i
came up here to atlanta and i was doing
a show at the miami lounge
um and one of the other comics on that
show was uh chris harvey who's a buddy
of mine so fantastic but this is my
first time i ever met him right and i
didn't know until i got to the club that
it was like an urban room
right so i'm already like a little in my
head about that because i haven't done a
lot of urban rooms because i'm i'm also
still like at this point a year and a
half into comedy you know so i haven't
done a lot of rooms period yeah
um
but so i'm already a little in my head
about that and then chris harvey comes
over to talk to me he's like hey man
like uh i saw like on social media
you're the guy that likes is like is
going to be featuring for jay and stuff
right and i was like oh yeah yeah and
he's like oh cool he's like i actually
featured for him in st louis at the
funny bone like the week before that
happened and they were talking about me
coming on the road and featuring for him
and i thought he was going to be like a
dick about it yeah like i was fully
prepared like as he's talking he was
like oh no
but instead he was like he couldn't have
been happier for me he's like dude i saw
like
a couple of your things like on social
media like i didn't have a whole bunch
at that point but he's like i saw a
couple of your videos and like dude your
whole vibe just fits his show's vibe
better than i could have you know and
he's like so i'm so happy for you blah
blah and then he like that he like after
that show that night he gave me like so
much like great like comedy big brother
advice like he was the one that like
gave me advice about like how to make my
merch and stuff like that and making
sure that i had merch he was like dude
if you're going with jason muse to these
big shows you need to have merch right
um and he's just throughout like still
gives me all sorts of like great advice
and stuff like that but he's just so
nice and congratulatory about how like
like i deserved this thing and all of
that and he's so happy for me and then i
went out to feature for him and
bombed my ass off
and in my head i was like the whole time
at every joke that's not going well and
i every single one i was like he's
getting more and more pissed that i got
that job
like every time and then the the only
other bombing story i have
um like a really good one isn't from
like an actual bomb
but i did the uh recently i did the
bloomington comedy festival right mm-hmm
and the headliner for one of my shows
was caitlyn palufo
dude yup dude you know where this is
going she is so funny okay like she's so
funny she makes me feel less funny dude
right yes okay so
she's the headliner for this show
i go up i do my set it's like eight
minutes or whatever i'm in my head i'm
like that went awesome right i come off
stage back to the back of the room where
she's at with the other comics and she's
like you know the other comics already
on stage she's like hey dude that was a
great set like knuckles all this kind of
stuff she's great yeah the headliner
liked my set yeah that comic that in
between us came off stage and then she
went on and two minutes into her set i
looked at the other comic that saw her
fist bump me and i said hey was she
[__] with me
because i literally she was so funny i
was like there's no way she actually
thought i was funny so you're like she
was so funny you thought you bombed is
that what you're like she was so funny
she had me like second guessing
everything oh yeah like because like i
was like no no she complimented me on my
set and i didn't do that yeah yeah like
it was that it was like she had to have
been [__] like she couldn't have
meant it like like in my head it made
literally so funny made me start
questioning myself but she but nice
people saying so fantastic you know so
she was genuine i'm sure yeah no
absolutely she was genuine after the
show she's like on her way out she was
like she was like uh your set was again
like so good blah blah blah like um like
reconfirm she still thought i was funny
it was like it was super nice but just
in that moment like like she just
complimented me i'm basking in this glow
you know what i mean really soaking in
that moment and then she just starts
crushing so hard but like it turned my
light off yeah you know what i mean
yeah you know i've every time i've seen
her
yeah it's it's there's just there's just
levels to this dude right there's just
levels to this at every turn whenever
you think you've got something figured
out you're gonna see someone who has
even more figured out so that's just
focusing on your own journey okay but
that but i view those kinds of things as
like challenges like okay she's i feel
like she's so much funnier than her
which means i have to put in so much
work to where i feel like i'm at that
level it's inspiring for sure yeah you
let it inspire you
yes okay i look at it as like almost
like uh like running like cross country
right if like you're running cross
country and like another runner passes
you
you can like be bummed about it or you
can just like fall in line behind that
runner and be like okay i'm gonna like
figure out what's like you know like
reduce my drag like figure out you know
something to figure out how i can keep
pace with this person yeah yeah so i do
think about it more like that but also
it's
cool this is like i don't like this is
like just one of those weird things so i
got asked like
like uh maybe a month after that
festival
to i got asked if i would be interested
in headlining a different comedy
festival with caitlyn paluffo so i was
like okay cool so in my head i was like
okay like i have to start stepping my
game up now
so that when i get there i don't feel
like i got buried in the dust you know
what i mean like i gotta i gotta all
right i gotta like get ready i gotta
prepare so i can come in here and prove
i belong in this category you know what
i mean and
yeah there's something about that like i
i think because i grew like i grew up
with like a coach dad you know yeah yeah
so like things like that like i don't
ever view like i don't ever i'm never
mad at somebody else for being like you
know like oh they're funnier oh [__] you
for writing that joke that i wish i
thought of like i just view it more as
like okay i gotta get better i gotta get
back in the gym you know i gotta get
stronger so i can keep competing because
to me like it's friendly competition
first like and it's yeah it's like i
think we're all salesmen for the same
company yeah you know what i mean yeah
yeah all yeah i think i'm hoping that's
a new that's the thing with hot breath
is like the community being positive and
supportive because when i started it was
very negative and competitive and i'm
hoping this new
kind of
culture and comedy is it seems to be
younger comics are helping comics each
other and there's so many examples of i
mean things bill burr has done to
produce comedy specials and things like
that and so many comics are doing that
so it's um i'm hoping that's kind of the
new norm in comedy is us helping each
other and realizing there's enough for
everyone well and so same like my early
experience in comedy was in like a small
like a smaller scene where there was a
lot of like drama and negativity and
then when i started getting on the road
i started realizing like oh like yeah
that exists and there is still a lot of
it in comedy there's also a lot more
optimism and positivity and like you're
right like the right tin and hot breath
network and like uh that night at the
punch line i met like five other hot
breathers yeah i did too awesome yeah
and uh and yeah like there's people from
that like hot breathers that i met at
that punchline event that like i'm still
friends with we still talk i'm staying
at one of their houses this weekend so i
don't have to pay for an airbnb the
entire time
you know awesome and so it's that it's
literally like we like we we built this
uh like fraternity right and it's kind
of like that like if you think about it
in that not like from like the sexist
standpoint but like not like it's not
like a man only thing but like uh what
would that be
a community
um and there's like a camaraderie it's
like a coed housing situation it's a
coed
fra
what do they call the bathrooms that you
can be either gender
i don't know i was trying to make them
bathrooms
yeah why do you got to come up with a
different name for him
[Music]
yeah gender neutral but i know what
you're saying not fraternally but like i
like community is all i can do yeah but
yeah a place for everyone yes yeah it is
a not a brotherhood but a family hood
we've created a family a family hood yes
indeed yeah okay um and it is cool like
like is like obviously it's one of those
things where like nev not everybody's
like
everybody's never gonna come on board
you know they're you're always gonna
have that you know those
negative people and stuff like that but
it's weird because like you i i've
noticed especially like the last several
years you notice like the people with
like the positive outlooks and the
people that are nice are the people that
end up getting nice things yeah for sure
you know and i do feel like it is kind
of turning that way so it's very cool
seeing that like oh this is something
like we've already been doing and i'm
not like not starting the trend but it's
cool to see that it is trending in that
direction for sure yeah yeah um
and it's also just it okay it's
the closest thing i've felt
since being in the army
if that makes sense comedy yeah wow
because it is it's like um like in the
military if you move from like one base
to another you're in an entirely new
squad entirely new like co-workers group
of people but it's there's still a
certain baseline level of camaraderie
because it's like hey we both signed up
to do this one thing that not everybody
else is brave enough to do true right
and i'm not saying the comedians are
brave by any stretch of the imagination
not trying to compare him to like our
nation's heroes of course not but there
is like a sense of camaraderie among
comedians and that like that sense of
camaraderie is the mo it's the closest
thing i've felt to that thing you have
in the military yeah i agree and so
that's been really cool like so it
doesn't matter like what city you're in
there's always going to be people in
that city like other comics in that city
that are going to be welcoming and
friendly and things like that of course
they recognize that same camaraderie and
familyhood
what what happened at the miami
nightclub you just said you bombed and
then that was it like no it was just it
was what was the bee
oh it was my regular material but at
that time like you just didn't get
laughs did they boo did they leave um
where's the heart break i didn't get all
i didn't get anywhere near the laughs
that i know like normally get and like
there were a couple jokes like when i
said i'm i was autistic like
uh like there was like such a like a
long silence and there was literally
like an older black woman and you could
just hear and she's like oh baby
like that
and like
like normally like there's like a
silence and i can ride that silence and
then come right back like ooh you feel
how uncomfortable everybody just got but
for them like they didn't get
uncomfortable they were just confused
and sad that yeah so that's why i
followed up because i i came up in urban
rooms in atlanta so like i know that
exact scene like that type of show
you're talking about so i wanted to
picture you in that moment like bombing
and like i said that was before i
learned that lesson about like start
with the thing that's unique about you
like why are you different start there
right so i started with like the generic
like absurdist material and like it was
funny but it was like nobody was really
engaged because they're all like what's
going on with them no connection yeah
so
um so i bummed and that was one of those
things he also brought up that night was
like dude you gotta like you have this
thing you need to lead off with this
thing like
throw the haymakers right out the gate
like you have to do that in these rooms
right
um
and so but it was like like i said it
was just doubly painful because i was
bombing in front of this dude that like
had in my mind at that period because i
had like had such like a negative start
to comedy in my head i was like he has
every right to absolutely hate me you
know but then he was so nice and so
supportive and now i'm bombing and he's
like i in his head he's like i take back
every nice thing i said to you like i
should be opening up for jake yeah like
in his head he was like die
nope
i was wrong you know
so that just made it like extra painful
and like even now like going back like
we joke about it now because he's like i
said he became like a mentor to me and
like a big brother and we still like
talk almost every week like about comedy
yeah but and so but just in my head like
my anxiety level was like oh now he
hates me
as you're bombing yeah i was like this
is going crazy yeah this is going so
poorly he changed his mind and he
totally hates me now
and then he was actually outside just
smoking he wasn't even watching you he
probably lost my first couple minutes
and he was like he should have started
with that other stuff and then went
outside yes a lot of times we're like oh
the comics are watching they're like no
they're they're outside they don't care
a lot of the time so yeah
so yeah that was really the the the real
painful part of that and then my only
other one uh
was a bo it was an open mic in orlando
florida
and i was hosting and i was coming off
of the road like i literally was coming
from a show like i just done a weekend
with jason muse i was like yeah i'm
doing great at this comedy course
come back to florida i'm do i've got a
weekend booked in orlando so i was like
yeah
and then uh another comic was like hey i
saw you're coming to do that do you want
to host copper rocket the night before
for an extra 50 bucks and i was like
yeah why not right i'm rich literally
during my host set
i say something about being autistic and
a drunk lady that didn't hear the full
thing was like you can't talk about
autistic people and i was like i am
autistic people
and she literally got like charred like
got to the point where she was trying to
like charge the stage and the guy who
booked me to host was having to stand
between her and the stage
yeah uh and you're are you still trying
to do material are you yelling back at
her at this point i'm like kind of
yelling back with her like back and
forth uh other people in the bar are
like booing at her telling her she's
wrong her day it turns out she was on a
first date the guy she was on the date
with i called her a karen at one point
during the interaction and he literally
turned and he's like she really is a
carrot
uh and so the bar eventually like i
finished my host set handed it off to
one of the other comics and then i went
like outside into the smoker's area
where the other comics were to like
catch my breath and calm down because
like literally i was like this is the
first time anything like that had ever
happened to me
still the only time something like
that's ever happened but so i was like
like outside some of the other comics
they're like trying to help me calm down
and the bar kicked her out her date
stayed to watch the rest of the show and
then she like because she was like angry
and pissy and whatever she like yelled
something and then like squealed her
tires out of like the parking lot
uh but like
[Music]
she was driving a nissan cube
and that something about that like still
to this day upsets me
it was a cube yeah
because like how dare you think you're
so right about something
and still drive a nissan cube like you
obviously don't make good decisions
in life in general right yeah yeah yeah
for sure
um wow but yeah so that was the only
other like real like bad bad story you
know
uh other than that like i just i started
bombing just like everybody else until i
stopped bombing yeah and now you never
bomb you're no no no i still i had a
bomb last night i feel like i did a
rooftop bar here in atlanta oh yeah and
uh
i was the last comic the show was
running a little long and then and then
it started raining and part of the
rooftop was open so half of the crowd
just left
so by the time i went up there was like
19 people and i think most of them were
also autistic
because they were by the end of it but
they were the kind that don't get humor
because they did not laugh much oops but
no it's one of those situations where
like after the show on the way out
people are like hey you were super funny
and it's like you should have told your
face sometimes people
that are just sitting there watching you
not even laughing are the ones that come
up after a lot of the times those are
the ones they're like oh i had a blast
thank you and you're like you didn't
even laugh once but okay yeah yeah he's
like no no no my face is just it i can't
move it much
dude i i'm so grateful we did this and i
totally forgot
i totally
forgot forgot your hot breath water
what i'm so embarrassed
i forgot to bring that out at the
beginning oh you could tell i was
getting the cod mouth couldn't you guys
we're talking about those
i don't know if you guys can tell in 4k
but i got those little like old man
white flecks around my mouth it's that
cotton mouth from that medical
mm-hmm
wait which you travel a lot i guess you
can just you have a car that you can
just have
i have my medical card in florida
um
a lot of states that like some of the
states i travel to that are like
recreational i can like get stuff from
there and then other times i break the
law
if you just travel with this stuff
you're like well sometimes yeah i feel
like if you have a medical card though
it should so because i'm a lawyer i have
i have like a video i put out on youtube
about that because i was like i was in
portland doing helium with jay
and uh i somebody at one of the shows
like literally brought
a big like a tupperware container full
of like like marijuana
and they were just like uh we've like
heard like we heard your story before
like we came
you're awesome like we want you to have
this and that like literally that
marijuana was so good i was sitting in
my hotel the next day i went outside i
smoked a joint of it i went back
upstairs and i called my girlfriend
because i was crying
and i was like like but like happy tears
like because literally i was like babe
like i'm so like relaxed and happy and
like de-stressed right now from this
weed and then i literally started
talking about like the weed and like i
was like like the way like the way i
feel right now like before i got
diagnosed there was like a couple year
stretch where i didn't think i'd ever
feel like happy again whoa you know and
like there was a period of time where
like
i was like calling the
like the va crisis line like
multiple times a week because i was like
afraid i would hurt myself right like i
just i did not want to live on this
planet anymore right um
but then like i started like i got
diagnosed and i started working with
like an autism specialist and therapist
then i got this medical marijuana card
and like i literally the joke is like i
have one i have those uh those like
tubes that like the pre-rolled joints
come in well some of them like they're
like they're like aluminum tubes and the
cap is like rounded and it'll be like
white and blue or like different colors
and they literally look like fortnite
bullets or like what i imagine a
fortnight bullet would look like and i
literally i made that joke that night in
portland i was like uh like so now like
whenever i like i get the big sads like
instead of like hurting myself i just
like unload one of these fortnite
bullets into my brain
you know and it's
so yeah it's
it like it not only gave me like the
[__] around and find out to like do this
but it also like
helped me like
get through like this
thing with my brain that like
it's one of those like uh what comes
first like the chicken or the egg kind
of thing like do i have depression and
anxiety
because like because i'm autistic or do
i have depression and anxiety because i
was autistic and went so long without
being treated and trying to like
basically like found unhealthy coconut
coping mechanisms from my brain that
caused these other things to develop i
don't know but i know that that helped
you know what i mean like when nothing
else i had tried in 30 years helped
so it's important to me and at this
point like
this is what i do for a living right
like i'm not gonna lose my job over
getting busted with marijuana
um and i like i'm a i'm a i'm an
i'm a service connected disabled veteran
i have my medical marijuana card in my
home state
if you really want to like arrest me for
having marijuana in a place where i'm
not supposed to have marijuana like i
will be the poster boy for getting this
law changed you know what i mean like
i've had like three or four people
already like
like basically uh offer to pay my bail
if that happens
because it's like it's unfair it's an
unfair system where somebody who like
who who has a medicine with a proven
documentation of how well it works for
them for them to not be able to have
that medicine like you don't tell a
person who's on like blood thinners they
can't have their medicine because they
cross the state line so it's one of
those things
wow yeah i was bringing up weed and you
brought up calling the crisis
oh man my bad dude i didn't i mean like
no it's just i appreciate you sharing
that though yeah but that's why like
like i said like i if i like most places
now it's a ticket
if somebody really wants to hold me off
to jail then we can do the whole thing
you know like i'm just
i'm at a point where i
i'd rather have it
you know what i mean i'd rather have
have it not need it than need it and not
have it and if that means that i have to
like bend some rules then let's go so
what was the
i know we're trying to land this plane
but it's like
what was the moment that you got
diagnosed because it sounds like you
were like a hermit you were depressed is
this like you were thinking about
hurting yourself and then
was getting help for that that what led
you to getting more information about
autism like yep so it took all the way
to where you were thinking about hurting
yourself i was at the va hospital in uh
cape coral florida down near fort myers
and i was trying to get information on
like how i could like basically turn
myself in
like to like for like a 72 hour hold i
was like i'm seriously afraid i might do
something to hurt myself in the next
like
several days like
i felt like i was in this downward
spiral that i couldn't get out of
and literally talking to like the nurse
as she's doing my intake stuff she just
looked up from the paperwork at one
point and was like have you ever like
been tested for autism and i was like no
why and she's like she's like uh she's
like like i obviously can't like
diagnose you or anything but i have a
nephew who's about your age and who's
autistic and like you just remind me of
him with several of the things that you
do
and so that night when i left the
er at the va she uh
gave me like some information to look
into and i started looking into it and
then i started i found like some
different online tests and started
taking those and every one of those was
like you should see a professional like
we like we have some bad news that we
just can't tell you you know and
eventually uh
like uh like i said i had already
started like withdrawing from society
like like well beyond like a normal rate
at that point and uh it had gotten so
bad i'd like i moved to fort myers to
move in with one of like my best friends
in the world
because i wanted somebody to keep an eye
on me wow
and so then i moved like i found out
that the only place in florida that
could really do like um like diagnoses
and like consultations and stuff for
adults was the university of florida and
that's near where i'm from like i grew
up in that area so i ended up moving
back to my parents house and going to
the university of florida and then
getting like my recommendation for
official diagnosis and then they sent me
to like a like a person to give me my
diagnosis
and then
like from there started kind of
climbing back out
wow because i it like getting for me it
was like uh
like imagine being born underground and
not knowing there was an above ground
and then all of a sudden someone was
like hey there is an above ground and
there are these tools you can use to get
there and i can teach you how to use
these tools it's like well i've just
been digging in random directions with
my hands for three decades so yeah
thanks that's awesome oh you know what i
mean yeah
um
so
yeah like ev that just changed
everything you know
yeah you said you kind of referenced
like uh you said bad news but sounds
like it was good news
you said you oh you then you be like oh
we have bad news for you like someone's
saying getting a diagnosis but it sounds
like it was good well no it was good
news well but that's what because so
many people think about it negatively
one of the first reactions i got from
someone was like hey i have bad news
about you being autistic yeah wow
yeah professional
a medical professional yeah i had
another medical professional and i have
a bit about this that i used to do but i
had another medical professional at the
va literally right on my like his little
notepad that he was taking notes with
during our session literally wrote
[__] strength and i read it upside
down i was like are you [__] serious
dude what yeah oh my gosh
yeah because he was asking me like um oh
sorry this battery is bad oh you're good
i was dead we're almost done though
dude this has been so much fun
yeah
i also didn't realize like uh
i guess because we like we have met
before and we have like a like i'm
familiar with you so you're not like a
stranger yeah dude i [__] haven't
been able to stop talking to you man
right now yeah i know like i feel like
i'm normally like kind of bottled up
around people until i get to like
interact with them a lot more oh whoa
yeah i feel like because i've watched
the show before and like i've been like
part of the network yeah it's like kind
of like the four stones like you're not
a stranger no more yeah
well good man
that's the whole goal with the
whole the whole show and the whole
community and everything is for people
to feel welcome you know
that's the whole goal
what is that your medical no this is uh
nicotine because i'm a piece of [__]
no
dude you're not a p it's it's called
florida dude really it's not
well i okay like comedians like i feel
like comedians as like a little usb
drive i know
but i feel like comedians as a whole are
keeping the tobacco industry alive oh
wow there's so many comics who like
started smoking because of comedy or
they relapsed back into it because of
smoking no i uh i am from florida and
i'm not from like the beachy palm tree
part of florida uh so between that and
then being in the army i dipped for like
a decade i puked every time i puked when
i tried it in high school but then when
like afterwards when i was in the army
somebody got me to try the pouches and
so i started with the pouches i puked
with the pouches too dude i just my my
beta male energy could not handle i
tried to look alpha with that dip in
dude i puked literally every single time
and i tried it a lot i wanted to like it
so bad and i just got sick every time
yeah i got used to it in the army and
then couldn't stop like i was already
addicted so i dipped for like a decade
so then i switched from dipping
to
vaping and so the plan is like uh like
by 2024 i want to be completely off
tobacco yeah you can do it yeah you can
do it i want to get like fresh start for
me and whoever our president's gonna be
then you got it so i got it we'll do a
follow-up then
and it'll be like both of our
inaugurations
it'll be like from this point forward
and i'll be like never again
i've had a friend who quit smoking and
they said that they just hated
themselves for a year and then it was
fine
yeah that's all yeah but everybody i did
that for everyone i did that for a
couple years i could i could squeak by
out one more yeah a year that's that's
child's play you got this
yeah but okay but i also like started
trying to quit around the same time that
i was like trying to get diagnosed and
stuff like that so it was a like try a
lot to try and balance all at once so i
was like you know what i'm just gonna
switch what i'm doing so like i don't
like lose my jaw
and then i'll figure out how to stop the
rest of it later yeah yeah you got it
yes i believe in you so
yeah well let's um let's land this plane
that was a good
that was a good sesh there yeah what um
is there anything else you want you want
the world to know or is there anything
we didn't cover anything um
i don't think so
no i don't think so where can people
follow you and
check you out um
ajwilkersoncomedy on instagram uh
ajwilkerson.com um
my
tic toc is captain autism comedy um but
everything's on my website you can find
all of it and then all of my tickets and
stuff are in my link tray linked in all
of my social medias so
yeah and you're you're doing a lot like
you're creating a lot i mean you you
press your own shirts but you're you're
doing your own
like skits and shooting all sorts of
stuff like so you're you're an example
of someone
in the in the comedy game that's like
you're not resting on like you're what
is working you're really trying to build
on what you're doing and trying a bunch
of different things and i think it's
important now as you mentioned swiss
army knife for comedians to realize that
it's like stand-up is like just one of
the many things that we can do so start
to look at how to diversify your skill
sets whether it is video and photo
editing and audio editing or it is doing
your own merch and things it's like what
else it's like it's like playing video
games
like if you like those like kind of
games where you like build your
characters and like specialize in
different things like it's like
literally a skill tree you like stand up
it might be your main skill tree it
might be the one you've like over you
like you want to develop the furthest
and be the strongest at but you still
have to develop other skills to like
make it through certain points of the
game and that's it's the same thing
um
[Music]
and uh
i love it me too i can't i can't do
anything else for a living anymore me
neither i'm i'm hooked
well if you uh if you could the last
thing i have comics do is look in the
camera and say their name and why people
should listen to hot breath
um
aj wilkerson look at us uh we do look
cute and uh you should listen to hot
breath
so joel doesn't have to do casting couch
interviews anymore
thank you
aj wilkerson thanks be on hot breath
absolutely man woo